hello Davey bros my name is David
Eagleman and here's my question to you
if you imagine that the progress of
science has brought us some distance to
understanding the entirety of science
how far would you say that distance is
do we understand 5% of all of us science
50% 80% that's my question to you
hi David Eagleman that's a great
question in certain areas of science one
might perhaps not me but experts in a
given area could tell you how far
they're along in completing all of the
interesting questions in that limited
area of science but for science as a
whole of course we have no idea how far
along we are we're not even sure that
the answer isn't nowhere arbitrarily
small it could be that the realm of
questions and the areas of science that
we do not yet understand as infinite in
size and in the knowable
in fact it often appears to be the case
because the more we learn the more we
seem to realize that we don't understand
the more questions we have this is
especially true in fundamental areas of
science where we're exploring new laws
and new forms of matter and it's not at
all clear that we'll ever exhaust the
vast amount of ignorance that we're
aware of not to speak of the vast amount
of ignorance that were not aware of so
it could be very small but equally well
it could be that the amount of science
or knowledge to absorb is finite that
might be the case there are no
indications of that so I think in many
areas of science and certainly in the
areas that I work in
particle physics what we know is
probably a very small part of what we
have yet to learn